this is a production of Cornell
University
nice to see everyone and today I'm going
to be talking about my Master's research
on the Apple microbiome
all right and so I want to start by
posing a large scale question of how do
we have fresh fruit and vegetables fresh
produce in the grocery store for so long
after uh harvest season for many of
these crops
that's one of those things where I just
kind of took it for granted growing up
and it wasn't until I started here that
I really began kind of asking questions
about the science
of how that happens and one of the
important things to um recognize is that
a lot of the fruits and vegetables that
we Harvest uh don't actually make it to
the grocery stores don't actually make
it to Consumers and 20 to 40 are lost
after harvest before making it into the
hands of consumers and this is
especially uh
relevant for developing countries that
don't have the same uh technology and of
why skill Refrigeration that we do
right and so this is a very important
issue
and the purpose of post Harvest biology
is to go and solve this issue and the
way we think about this scientifically
is asking all right so what are the the
different uh aspects different forces
that make produce go bad and then how do
we stop that from happening to keep
produce from to keep produce staying
good
and this is not an exhaustive list
um of everything mostly trying to hit
the big points
of uh what we do in post-harvest biology
so I'm going to go through some of these
a bit more uh starting with ripening and
senescence that the more uh
plant tissues respire the faster they
represents because that's what controls
a lot of metabolism
right and so there are a few ways we
know to slow respiration Refrigeration
is a common technique that helps out
with many of the issues
that we have and a couple uh
technologies that I'm going to be
talking about in particular that I'm
going to be using in my research are low
atmosphere controlled oxygen uh storage
and reducing the uh the production and
perception of a hormone Ethylene
all right so first going into control
atmosphere storage
so the point of this is that instead of
just storing
um produce such as apples in cold air
with 21 oxygen we can you we can
artificially lower that down to 0.5 to 2
percent
and depending on the cultivar and
elevating CO2 and the main reason we do
this
is because oxygen as we all know is very
important for cellular respiration acts
as the final electron acceptor so if we
reduce the concentration of oxygen we
reduce the rate
which cellular respiration happens and
slow down metabolism in general
and one of the aspects that I'm not
going to be directly working with here
but
I think it's good to mention is a new
Improvement on this technology Dynamic
controlled atmosphere that allows us to
potentially take oxygen levels even
lower and maintain high quality because
the reason we don't bring oxygen all the
way down to zero is if you remember back
to basic biology that there's no Oxygen
cells will undergo fermentation and burn
through their sugars very quickly
and that's not what we want so Dynamic
controlled atmosphere allows us to
monitor the apples to ensure that that's
not happening while keeping the oxygen
as low as possible
essentially to minimize the overall
level of respiration
all right and then another
um important aspect of ripening and post
Harvest especially for fruits such as
apples
as a hormone ethylene so ethylene is a
hormone that has a variety of different
effects and the most relevant one to
post Harvest physiology
is that many fruits called climate chalk
fruits such as apples
will at a certain point in their
development produce a lot of ethylene
very quickly and what that does
as that stimulates respiration to go up
for this time and so if you can imagine
if we cut off this ethylene production
we can smooth out this respiration graph
and lower the amount of respiration
maintain the fruits quality for much
longer
especially important for fruits like
apples compared to something like banana
where we want some ripening after we
pick it we don't want to eat just green
bananas but with apples we prefer them
to be exactly how they are after we pick
them off the tree
right and so then of course the question
is great we would love to inhibit
ethylene how do we actually do that
and there are a few a couple different
ways that uh going to go through talking
about how we do that so here I have the
Ethylene
biosynthesis pathway
where we have this chemical sand that's
converted to ACC and then oxidized into
Ethylene
and the two chemicals I'll be talking
about one that I'm using my experiments
AVG basically stops this synthesis
pathway so you cut off the synthesis of
Ethylene and again so the ethylene
concentrations are much lower
um and we don't get that climacteric
this increased respiration
and uh or at least the climate shark is
greatly reduced
um and and the other way
um one of the other major ways you can
reduce uh ethylene chemically is with a
compound that the Watkins lab has been
investigating for a long time one mCP
that's a compound that I am going to be
using uh in some of my PhD work looking
at the effects of that on the microbiome
but for here
uh for an asterisk work I'm mostly just
focusing on AVG but one mCP is still
very important and it doesn't directly
directly reduce the uh
synthesis of ethylene but it does stop
ethylene from affecting the cells in
ways that would increase respiration by
stopping the perception
ethylene and then the next point I like
to walk uh people through is reducing
water loss no one wants to like go in
and eat like a super shriveled Apple
that's lost all of its water
right and so how do we uh prevent that
from happening again refrigeration and
then if you pack a bunch of fruit
together
there's less surface area and then one
of the main ways we reduce water losses
by trying to keep these Commodities in
high humidity
right and by the picture here of apples
with a bunch of water on them and that
for anyone who's worked with fruit of
vegetables this should probably set off
warning signs if you have water all over
your fruit that's kind of dangerous and
um why is that not not that Apple's a 95
humidity actually look like this but uh
the principle applies that if you have a
lot of humidity a lot of water it can be
kind of dangerous for the fruit because
of post-harvest pathogens right and so a
lot of us are familiar
are pathogens that affect uh apples
apples and other fruits and vegetables
in the field and many of these pathogens
can also affect apples during storage
right something like better rot you see
here affecting an apple in the field
pretty a pretty big problem during
storage as well
and we can control these uh molds and
rots a variety of ways Refrigeration
helps with many of them
you can also use fungicides but those do
have certain limitations there are
certain regulatory concerns
around conventional fungicides not that
there aren't around other types of
fungicides as well and also it's
becoming more and more difficult to
discover new modes of action for
fungicides
so certain researchers have thought
about okay what are some other
um techniques we can use to help control
these uh Hotel restaurants involved and
one of the ideas they've settled on
I was biocontrol where basically the
idea is instead of just
spraying a chem a chemically synthesized
compound to uh so some compound to
synthesized in a lab
to go off these post-service pathogens
you add on live organisms to antagonize
those pathogens or products from those
organisms
and it sounds kind of great in theory if
it works it's like you don't have to
spray all these like chemicals that
consumers don't like
um
on the fruit you just put the microbes
that chase off the Bad microbes but
there are some limitations to this
approach as well that it only has a full
efficacy under certain conditions
because you are working with
um
in many cases live organisms so they're
uh that their ability to actually
control the uh pathogens is much more
context dependent
and they're not always quite as
commercially competitive compared to
conventional fungicides on all our scale
but there are still commercial options
available and people are working on
trying to improve them and then one
piece that uh many of these
uh post horseback control researchers
are thinking as could potentially be the
missing link is the microbiome
right because
um we think of the traditional way we
think of biocontrol as you add
a microbe to the fruit surface and it
will fight off the pathogen but the
truth is the anything we see on on the
fruit surface there are lots of
different microbes there
and the way I like to think about it is
that the fruit surface is kind of like a
tiny forest
and that if you add
and then if a forest if there's one
species under control if you add in
another species to try and control it
taking lessons from basic ecology you
need to make sure that the biocontrol
species you're adding in not only can
fight off the organism you don't like
the the pathogen that's causing problems
but also that it fits well into the
context of a local environment
right and so that's somewhat difficult
to do because we don't know what a lot
of these microbes do functionally
but it's a exciting New Frontier for
people to explore
and could potentially in the long term
lead to Greater efficacy for biocontrol
as a real alternative
um to conventional fungicides
right
and then another piece of theory for why
um people
I'll put so much stress on this
microbiome fruit surface microgram is
taking from uh the human microbiome
studies that developed this Theory
called the Hall of Bion Theory which
basically states that the way humans
work as a like individual is not just
based on human physiology but the
interaction of human physiology and
microbial physiology
you know there's been a lot of amazing
work from the human microbiome
a world with uh
pretty stunning results such as the fact
that like gut microbes can release
neurotransmitters that can affect brain
signaling um so even the fundamental
ways we act as a human are sort of in
conversation with the microbes
either live in and on us and so people
in the post-harvest physiology world of
have thought okay why don't we apply
that to fruit surfaces that
it would make sense that because
microbial ecology is so complicated that
everything we think about of of how
these fruits actually function
and storage there's a conversation
between frit physiology and microbial
ecology and that's going to be one of
the big Ideas behind my research
right
and then as a bit of a like fun side
note
um that Jenny today brought in this
Apple for for demonstration and
fun thought experiments is when we
actually eat an apple like this how many
bacteria are we consuming
all right and then looking at there was
a study that investigated how many uh
bacteria there are on per gram of
different parts of the Apple looking at
the stem peel the flesh within and then
the seeds at the very core so I'm not
gonna like uh call on people like it's a
class but I want to give everyone a
second to think like how many uh
bacteria do we expect there to be
program of uh fruit tissue in these
different parts
okay so I'm just going to wait a few
seconds to give everyone a little bit of
time to think about like what what's
flood ballpark
yeah
under the eighth and
some of those are yeah one like in the
stem part and the seeds part that's very
close
program
so so congrats to Bill Miller
on that and then we see there's there's
26 and the V8
and we see that there's a lot of
variation in different parts
of the apple and that uh some of this I
feel like is was surprising to me but
somewhat intuitive that like the the
Woody parts woodier parts of the tissue
like the stem
um have more bacteria like you wouldn't
want your kid like eating that or
putting your mouth all over it that
makes sense that we have that impression
because there are lots and lots of
bacteria on it
all right and so like I talked about one
of the key ideas of my work is combining
the microbial calls you've been talking
about for the past few slides with the
post-harvest physiology problems that I
was talking about at the very beginning
yep and so that leads into my specific
research question how do AVG and control
atmosphere storage
affect the Apple surface microbiome
right and I'm going to go through
again what uh what these two
technologies are and what we expect them
to do first
so AVG which can come in the form of
this powder that you dissolve
dissolve in a liquid and then spray uh
on the
fruits pre-harvest
um is an inhibitor of Ethylene
biosynthesis
so it stops ethylene from uh being
synthesized which slows down ripening
and senescence and the question is
why would we expect that to affect the
surface microbiome well as I mentioned
ethylene is a hormone that has a variety
of functions
and we know that a couple important
things
we know about ethylene is that it does
modulate
um plant pathogen interactions it's not
a huge stretch to say well there might
be something there and how how it
interacts with the whole microbiome and
also we know that certain microbes
there's a certain bacteria can
synthesize Ethylene
I'm going to use it as a potential
signaling molecule so interrupting
ethylene Dynamics could
have some pretty drastic effects on the
microbiome
and then with a controlled atmosphere
storage
it seems kind of intuitive to wonder
okay
so the point of control atmosphere
storage is to slow down aerobic
respiration wouldn't that affect the
microbes on the surface as well as the
Apple itself and we know that
certain Studies have shown that it does
suppress pathogen growth not that it
like directly kills off pathogens for
the most part but it does something from
growing as quickly and it can't
interfere with bio control that if you
put a biocontrol organism on that it
doesn't always behave in full efficacy
when it's
not able to use respiration on full
efficiency and
grow to actually antagonize the pathogen
and so we're wondering how does this
impact the whole microbiome
and then
um since this is Master's defense we
want it to be kind of very uh uh
meticulous about making sure that our
whole hypothesis is clear to everyone
um
so our hypothesis is that uh AVG will
shift the microbiome due to as I
mentioned ethylene modulating plant
microbe interactions
and then also ethylene being a bacterial
uh and a microbial signaling molecule
and then we predict that a control
atmosphere will create a different
microbiome than air storage due to low
oxygen and this will be pronounced more
pronounced at lower uh concentrations of
oxygen
all right so now I'm going to go a bit
into my experimental design
where one of the difficulties of looking
at
um controlled atmosphere compared to air
is the fact that uh
that we weren't able to have a
the same sampling times for every
treatment because we were interested in
looking at control Dems here at the very
end of its lifespan
um but we can't air store apples for
that long using our methods
so we have three and five months air
storage and then
five and nine months for um are to
controlled atmosphere uh
treatments two percent and point five
percent
oxygen
and then to give a sort of like broad
overview of what we did to actually get
the the data we're working with
I mean I'll go into a bit more detail
with some of the steps
then we take our apples uh tables per
sample we are able to put them in a wash
solution and get the microbial pellet
from them
uh we use are able to extract
the DNA and then amplify a known region
to get these amplicons that are then
sequenced and we use bioinformatics to
get a big multivariate feature table
all right so let's go through some of
that in a bit more detail all right so a
lot of times when I get questions about
like how do you actually get the
microbes off an apple there are
different ways you can do it
um the method we used that we found was
most consistent
and once you basically put the apples in
a bag with a wash solution
um containing a surfactant basic salt
use a sonicator bath to use the sock
waves to knock off the microbes and then
use this rotary Shaker to just shake the
apples around in a bag which looks kind
of funny when you see it for the first
time
take the solution uh filter it through
using vacuum filtration and scrape off
the grime and that is our microbial
pellet that we use a DNA extraction kit
on to get the DNA that gets sequenced
right and I talked a bit about this
um
and the overview slide
but the method of sequencing we're using
here is amplicon sequencing so we're not
going through and sequencing entire
genomes of entire bacteria and fungi
because that's very expensive
um especially to do for an entire
microbiome what we're doing is we're
taking part of a known Gene if you've
ever heard of 16s or its sequencing
that's what this refers to do pcrs you
get to amplify uh
to to get amplicons many many copies
of that region for each DNA strand and
then sequence those to then see what
those microbes are if we can we can map
them back onto reference genomes later
and the upside of this is that we can
use this and get a lot of samples so we
can actually do stats um
but the downside is we don't always get
species level identification so that's
one good thing to keep in mind
with all the data I'm going to be
showing is that we get a general idea of
who's there but not down to the species
level which can be impactful
all right
and then again because
um
this is the Master's uh defense by the
Master's defense
we decided it was a good idea to be
pretty uh explicit about a lot of the
different methods we were using
even if it gets a little bit technical
at times so I'm just gonna ask you to
bear with me
so once we get our actual DNA sequences
back what we do is we use a program to
do a bunch of filtering we merge the
forward and reverse reads
um if you have done Illumina sequencing
before you've there's a good chance
you've worked
without merging reads and then you get
these what are known as asvs so which
gives us a table of okay here are all
the different
um DNA sequences and here are how many
copies we have of each one
what we do then which is optional some
people like to do this some people don't
is say okay all of these uh DNA
sequences with 97 similarity we're going
to basically regard as the same thing
basically the same uh type of microbe
not quite a species because again we
don't always get species of
identification but something kind of
similar that is not species specific
necessarily
um and so we then get those what are
called operational taxonomic units or
otus
and we can use that table to directly
perform steps on we can classify the
taxonomy for them
and then we can also all go into a bit
more of this later
predict the gene Pathways of those
reference genomes which can potentially
tell us more about what those bacteria
are doing for bacteria only we
unfortunately don't have the the program
doesn't work for fungi at least yet
all right
and then going into the some of the
stats parameters as well in case anyone
um
is interested in exactly how I did this
or wants to work with microbiomes in the
future one of the big debates in the
field is whether or not you verify
basically cut out data until every
sample has the same
um
number of reads the same number of uh
microbe counts and I chose not to do
this because the argument for doing this
is
well you want to make sure like each
sample has the same amount of data so
you can actually compare it them but my
my stance is that it's better to just
use kind of the full data set to make
each sample the most accurate it can
possibly be
um
and then we basically as a result of
this because we're working with the
large ecological data set we get this
huge multivariate data frame
and the way we calculate statistical
tests on what's different is using this
brake Curtis dissimilarity Matrix
instead of a standard like uh euclidean
distance where you would just subtract a
bunch of things basically the functional
difference here is that it handles zero
is better in the data set
um and then we were able to do a lot of
multiple testing to find which Gene
Pathways in which uh Genera are
significantly different between some of
our comparisons
and for that we used a false discovery
uh rate correction that is a bit more
lenient than a than a standard like
bonferoni where you just multiply the
p-values by the number of tests running
but this is still statistically valid
they can let us find
um some interesting Trends and then
there are somewhere
I do an anova and then I do the standard
post-op Tookie test to compare different
uh pairwise treatments
all right so actually getting into the
data the first thing
I'm going to be showing here is uh the
internal ethylene so as I mentioned we
expect AVG to
uh decrease ethylene production you see
here just looking at air storage these
gray points definitely see that it does
that for the when ethylene is not added
we see it starts higher and Rises very
quickly but when AVG is added
um we see that it it stays much lower
than um
than the control and then when we look
at the controlled atmosphere treatments
here we see that a controlled atmosphere
does keep
um ethylene levels lower than in air
storage which we expect and that even
within these treatments these
circles here are have higher ethylene
than the triangles that represents the
AVG
applied so basically this is telling us
exactly what we expect to see and they
confirms that like yes our controlled
atmosphere at our AVG did work how we
thought it would AVG reduces ethylene
controlled atmosphere reduces methylene
all right and then
going into the actual microbial data
um
I know a lot of people like uh don't
have a ton of experience reading these
ordination plots and working with these
huge multivariate data sets so I think
it's a good idea to
walk people through kind of what these
mean and how to read them
so a couple key points to understand are
each point here represents a microbiome
of one sample so the ten Apples that we
put in the bag get the bacteria infantry
off of each one of those samples is one
point on here
and a lot of people when I show these
graphs ask okay well what do the axes
mean if something's higher on the x-axis
or the y-axis what does that mean
and the answer is uh it doesn't
intrinsically like
it's not intrinsically measuring
anything except just the distance
between the points matters
right so that when we have this huge
multivariate data set you can't always
get like a super intuitive like oh this
is a better microbiome versus a worse
microbiome all you can do is say with
these huge number of variables you have
going around we can collapse them into
two dimensions and the points that kind
of cluster together and that are more
similar are closer to each other in this
multi-dimensional space have microbiomes
that are more similar
right and so uh the the way to read
these is to look for certain clusters of
microbiomes that cost or buy uh or
different treatments and then here we
don't really see anything it looks like
the points colors and shapes are just
kind of scattered randomly and the stats
line up with that then when we look at
these fungi here we don't really uh
observe that our different storage type
storage times or AVG treatment
uh impacts the microbiome
and that when we look at uh bacteria on
the other hand we do see a bit more
clustering and uh to me the way I would
this guy that's trying to make it as
simple as possible is the points of
different colors are kind of cluster
together they're more uh closer to each
other in space
than they are to the other points and we
see that the stats tell us a storage
type and time which we're using as just
one variable here since our sampling uh
was a bit complicated and AVG treatment
are both significant predictors of
microbiome variation
and Visually the way uh uh I point this
out not that the circle is based on the
stats
it's at these points here these dark red
blue points that represent
um the nine months time point for our
both our controlled atmosphere are 0.5
and our two percent oxygen treatments
are pretty different pretty far apart on
the in this multivariate space
from all these other points so my main
takeaway from this is that after nine
months we get of low oxygen storage we
get microbiomes that look pretty
different from
uh most of the other time points
right and then going into results next
for fungi we didn't find any difference
in the composition of uh microbes we
also don't really find any difference
in the the diversity which is how many
fungi there are and how equally they're
spread
right so all these points are we don't
really see any significant differences
we also don't see a difference with
uh evg
but with bacteria we do we see that with
this long-term low oxygen storage you
see that diversity goes down a bit
um AVG doesn't
in fact significantly but storage time
slash type does
my uh
if I had to like try to interpret this
um my best guess is that there just
aren't that many different types of
bacteria that can survive nine months
under this is 0.5 percent
oxygen storage
um so because of that we see the
diversity is lower because there aren't
as many different types of bacteria that
can survive there
right and so now I'm going to go into
um
talking about
what I did with the predicted Gene
pathway data and I was told to warn
everyone that like
uh like the the the the stuff we've
dealt with before is not necessarily
like super basic but this can get
somewhat Technical and it's important to
understand kind of what this data is and
what the data isn't
um
so what we're doing is we're taking
these amplicons what we have are these
tiny DNA tiny DNA uh
regions that are sequenced we're
matching them to reference genomes and
we're saying okay what Gene Pathways do
these reference genomes have
we'll add these to our uh big table of
uh different counts for Gene Pathways
and then see how those vary with our
treatments
right and so in this case with the
example if we have five different
um
DNA strands to match up with this
reference genome we would say take all
of these uh
so you got the gene pathways on here and
add five counts in our big table and
here the same with these two strands of
mashup to this second reference genome
right
and then another reminder looking back
at our sampling schematic
um I was really interested in comparing
between air and our controlled
atmosphere
and the question is well what what time
points do you compare you can compare
them all when they're at five months but
in that case those air apples are really
latent storage when the control
atmosphere apples are still earlier in
storage so you'll get differences in
physiology there
um you can also compare when they're
both early in storage but then maybe the
fact that the bacteria have had more
time to like build up for five months
um in the control atmosphere and impact
the results and then same when they're
both latent storage so here I have
basically when I do these comparisons I
have I'm doing three different
comparisons a three months error versus
five months controlled atmosphere five
months Air versus five months controlled
at us here and nine months controlled
atmosphere versus uh five months there
right and basically what we see is that
this uh comparison between controlled
atmosphere nine months kind of very late
in storage when we have low oxygen
compared to
as late as we can store air apples we
see the biggest differences
um so on the left here we're looking at
the different Genera
and we see that about 30 percent of them
uh change in abundance
um with with this comparison looking at
nine miles control I'm a service is five
months error
and then over here remember like the
gene Pathways we find that it's also
about 30 that increase or decrease
significantly with this comparison and
so the question then arises all right so
we have all these Gene Pathways that are
different between this comparison when
we look at nine months very latent
storage for atmosphere versus five
months and our storage also uh latent
storage time so what are these Gene
Pathways and what can they tell us
and the trends that I was able to find
the
big ones the first one that stuck out to
me was uh that
a lot of the gene Pathways that decrease
in abundance in the controlled
atmosphere and the low oxygen
are responsible for aromatic degradation
compared to
integration Pathways and all Pathways in
general
and I'm guessing some of the Apple
people are when you hear aromatics you
think about like Esters and apple Aroma
compounds this
the the tool that I used for this
defines aromatics using the organic
chemistry definition so compounds with
Benzene rings
so uh the
um the translation there isn't quite one
to one so the interpretation is a little
more tricky
and then over here uh the other one of
the other starting things I noticed is
that
um the the pathways that use
oxygen as a reactant
when we have long-term Low Air store low
oxygen
storage those Pathways tend to be
decreasing abundance which is fairly
intuitive that if you have
very low auction for a long amount of
time the bacteria that are selected for
probably have fewer pathways
for using oxygen and at this point I
took a step back
and said to myself okay well like I want
to make sure that because this
metagenomic data is so complicated
I want to make sure that I'm not uh
making a whole story out of nothing
so I compared oxygen
which again is functions as the final
electron acceptor during
um
so respiration and in general has many
other roles so as an Electronics after
with other common electron acceptors
um and found that those ones didn't
share the same Trend though of a caveat
is that like I'm not a trained like cell
biochemist if there are other
interesting compounds that oxygen should
be compared to here I'd be happy to hear
them
but this basically suggests that oxygen
but not compounds that have similar
roles are decreased in long-term low
oxygen storage uh the percent of
Pathways using oxygen as a reactant
that's confirmed as we go through and
instead of looking at how many Pathways
significantly increase or decrease
looking at okay let's take all the
pathways with different compounds as a
reactant
I'm going to add them all up that we see
the these couple of this dark gray and
black point here
representing air storage about 10.5
percent of the uh Pathways that they
have use oxygen and for this long-term
0.5 oxygen Storage Point it's about uh
9.5 percent of Pathways and then that
difference is statistically significant
and that with the other common electron
acceptors that we observe we don't
really see the same Trend uh
that hear these long-term low oxygen uh
time points don't decrease in NAD plus
and they also don't decrease in nadp
Plus
so it does seem to hence that
um that there's the strong potential for
the low oxygen
um
treatment to be impacting the microbiome
okay by uh
selecting against Pathways that require
oxygen the uh which is very exciting
because a lot of the microbiome studies
because we don't get species of
identification aren't really able to
make
those claims but I also do want to like
take a step back and say that uh because
we're looking at again what's the
equivalent of like an entire Forest just
microscopic
it's important not to like over
interpret from this data and there are
some aspects of it that make it so that
I don't feel comfortable definitively
saying this is the case the biggest one
is that at five months time points when
we
look at the different treatments we
don't really see any difference when
they're all at five months at nine
months we do but at five months we don't
so is that that
um oxygen is low oxygen is selecting on
Pathways that require oxygen but it just
takes a long time to uh for us to see
Real Results or is it the fact that
we're able to store these apples for
nine months or that there's something
else about that that decreases the these
path the abundance of these Pathways
that happen to require oxygen it's kind
of unclear right about now but I also
think it's exciting that we're able to
tie this uh potential
for this functional explanation of uh
oxygen and Pathways requiring it to
these microbiome uh composition changes
which a lot of similar studies haven't
quite been able to do
right and so that was kind of technical
let's Zoom back a bit and um summarize
what we found here
so the big points are we found that
um our storage time and type low oxygen
storage
time as well as uh this ethylene
inhibitor ABG treatment impact the
bacterial microbioma but we don't really
find any evidence that they impact the
fungal microbiome
and those impacts on the microbiome we
also find that uh oxygen Pathways using
oxygen Pathways for degrading aromatic
compounds
or decrease in abundance late in uh
storage for
a controlled atmosphere when compared to
air storage and there's the potential
for that to be related to the lack of
oxygen selecting on the community but
it's not
um super conclusive at this point
all right
and then I'd like to say thanks to
my advisors in my committee all the
people that I've collaborated with not
necessarily on this project but in a lot
of the work that we'll be doing is my
PhD
and then president former lab members
that helped me in the way and then also
my fund sources thanks for listening
honor so does the Apple itself matter in
the microbiome that you measured in
other words if you just had like
um a wood block and you covered it with
wax and then inoculated it with bacteria
you think you would
come out with similar results or do you
think that there's some interaction
between the bacterial community and the
Apple that
is is not you know clear from what you
measured here yeah that's a great
question and
um
I would say like
however I answer that is
oh yes yes
so so the question is to what extent
does the fact that these um microbes are
on an Apple service actually matter if
they were on just any sort of other
surface um would we see the same results
and the answer is
there are a lot of studies that look on
microbial communities of surfaces like
not usually like wooden blocks
necessarily but like on the walls here
and we do see some differences in
microbiomes um between say like what is
on the wall or what is on the chair
versus like what what we would find on
an apple
um in terms of uh specific uh aspects of
why being on an Apple would drastically
affect the microbiome compared to
another surface that's one of the things
that um to my understanding the field is
still like working on establishing like
what the actual kind of key
um relationships are
um that's more than likely uh the the
plant microbe interactions do have an
effect on the microbiome but
characterizing exactly what those are
because there are so many different
microbes and we don't know what all of
them are doing
um is a bit tricky
foreign
to be something that's changing the
microbiome because you plan on looking
at that interaction if so how would you
know that it's the decreasing and
ethylene itself rather than the addition
of this compound
so yeah the the question
so the question was
um
like what would I do to distinguish
between the fact that this compound is
being applied versus the actual um
reduction in ethylene itself
and there are there are like a few ways
um
I could potentially do that like there
is a compound called epiphon that like
where you can basically artificially add
ethylene
um the the way
um
a lot of people in apple Community see
it is that um the variation due to
um when you apply this chemical the the
effect it has is like so strong in terms
of ethylene that it is like a pretty
decent standard that it's has a huge
effect on the on the ethylene levels
um and that it it is somewhat regularly
used as like a stand-in for we apply
this
uh
compound ethylene decreases we see these
effects most likely due to ethylene um
one thing I will say is that when I
did the multivariate analysis for
um
whether or not like ethylene levels of
ethylene itself affect the microbiome
it came back negative which is most
likely due to the fact that like most of
the variation we see in ethylene is due
to this compound
um so kind of small bits of variation
within that we see we didn't we saw it
didn't really affect the microbiome
um so that's kind of my answer is that
like
uh the compound is used as a stand-in
for something that just decreases
definitely those big differences affect
the microbiome we don't see the same
thing for the small natural variation
when we don't use the compound
like one mole
yes
we have one sort of it might be similar
to a great question but do you or do
folks know where the majority of these
species are coming from in terms of
you're looking at them in the storage
setting and then I guess with that like
do you have ideas to why the stem makes
sense to me but seeing that seeds also
have like significantly more bacterial
species than other parts do you know why
that you have an idea yeah the question
is
um so can you repeat the first part of
that yeah just like are they are most of
these species originating in the field
yeah the question is um where do these
uh species come from
and the second part is uh we saw that
the seeds have a lot of different
um I have a very high counts of
a bacteria compared to some of the other
um
areas of the apple and why do I think
that is so for the first part where do
these uh microbes
come from um
it's not super clear and that's one of
the things that I am
hoping to work with on my PhD is looking
into
uh where these microbes actually come
from there's been some work in the field
trying to distinguish okay like how does
dispersal actually happen some people
have suggested it's uh due to soil the
fact that the wind picks up microbes
from the soil and deposits them
um so these above ground areas that's
the key factor other people have said
well maybe it's like rain or insects
or so and so when we look at post
Harvest when we do uh
uh when there there are some basically
statistical things we can do to assess
okay is are the changes we see due to
the microbes that are already there just
increasing and decreasing and abundance
or are there new microbes being added on
as well and we do see that there are new
microbes being added on as well in
ecological terms there is turnover
there's not just
um
a nestedness is the the term we would
use the question of how exactly does
that happen we're not totally sure
uh Geneva I have a question yeah Zoom
are there any any questions
Maria
H differences between the
yeah but it also sounded like in the
beginning you guys you guys were talking
about the spring fungicides as post
Harvest control of diseases like uh do
you have and also like products people
that are commercially available for
Disease Control and you're talking about
how that's not super effective right now
but do you have any thoughts about like
why we use fungicides for Disease
Control or fungal diseases but yet
you're not actually seeing differences
in your local communities basically all
right so the question is
now we don't see that the um fundra and
my experiment
um
the the microbiomes change with a lot of
treatments and the question is okay in
that context why why is there so much
emphasis on these fungicides if we see
that these fungal communities are kind
of hard to change
and so kind of two-part answer to that
question first is
um and I think this highlights that some
of the complexity of these microbial
communities this experiment we didn't
really see any changes of the fungal
communities some of the other
experiments we definitely have
um
and when we test different factors and
then the other point is
the best fungicides in my mind are ones
that don't necessarily
um have these huge impacts on the entire
microbial community that if we're
targeting a specific pathogen
um you spray the fungicide that targets
um that that one pathogen the
leaves the rest of the um microbes
untouched there are some people who have
postulated that like that's a good thing
for um
for like fruit Health that uh if you're
not changing the microbial Community as
much
um then that can be better but but
another big concern is that if you're
using these like multi-side fungicides
that are more likely to kind of disrupt
all the fungi
um
do those also have a bigger risk of just
being harmful to humans the the more
specific you are targeting the one fungi
you need a Target
um the lower risk there is of It kind of
going awry and targeting anything else
that you don't want it to Target
um my question is also about your focal
data you mentioned that it was hard to
get really great resolution and this is
kind of asking you to speculate but I
wonder
if you have a sense of whether
you know the fact that you weren't able
to see shifts in the fungal microbial
biome had to do with the fact that you
couldn't that you didn't have a very
fine resolution you know maybe they're a
worse relationship but it because you're
only looking engineer or something you
didn't see those shifts yeah the
question is
um I mentioned that we don't always have
species level resolution so like could
the fact that I didn't see any
difference in the in the fungi be due to
the fact that there were shifts but just
on a level that we couldn't detect
and the answer is that potential is
absolutely there I mean if it were
happening I would have no way of knowing
just because I can't detect it
my um
my my best guess is that that is not the
is that those shifts are not going to be
the most impactful that a lot of times
um and again it's like hard to compare
because there aren't a ton of studies
that really go in with these kind of
deep high resolution sequencing so it's
kind of hard to compare
but we see a lot of studies both on
Apple surfaces and on the surfaces of
other fruits like grapes and then also
in soils and in humans where we are able
to detect a lot of really substantial
differences
and the fungal Community is based on
whatever treatments we apply
so to me that seems to imply that like
the lack of resolution may be an impact
but
there's still the potential to see lots
of big differences
um here and I wouldn't say that the
resolution issue is the biggest reason
why I think we didn't see differences if
I had to guess
anybody else
one more for you Connor so uh you
introduced the topic about the human
microbiome or gut microbiota so
um do you you know you aren't you eat
right so do you think that there are
human health differences
based on the Apple microbiome in terms
of the different types of storages in
terms of what we can expect for human
health so the question is
um
because I talked about the human
microbiome do I think that the
differences in the microbiomes I find on
the apples could also have a human
health impact when looking at the human
microbiome and the answer is
um
there have been
I've I've heard people feel very
strongly both ways that I've heard some
people in these uh
for microbiome studies being like yes
like it's really important to like know
what microbes are on there because like
these could be super powerful for human
health
and that we see that a human and that
microbiome does depend on on diet is a
pretty well established thing
but then the other side of the coin is
people saying
well like most of these microbes are
probably just getting destroyed by
stomach acid anyways so we do see some
differences
based on diet but that's more likely to
be due to like the nutritional
composition of what goes into the gut
than the actual microbes
um that came in of course that itself is
complicated too because it's not like
not all of our microbes can
are being destroyed by stomach acid
because stuff like food poisoning still
happens for microbes based on stuff we
consume
So my answer is basically like I think
it's a possibility
um it and that's a very contentious
question right now
all right well please uh join me and
all right thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu